hi i'm riya today our friend will be
challenging me to take a popular food
and make it fancy today's guest eats
tang chun hi i'm kanchan and i am super
excited to challenge rye to make maggie
fancy i grew up in india where maggie is
pure comfort food the umami salty spicy
brothy maggie noodles were just a party
in the mouth and like a hug in a bowl i
know she's gonna do something super cool
and i cannot wait to see what it is
maggie
maggie is masala flavored instant
noodles and i've never had this before
it is smaller than i thought [ __ ]
seasoning very fragrant the color of
curry this is actually reminds me of our
first episode marchand noodle i kind of
had a flashback looks cool but i want to
try it
this is delicious it's not too spicy and
it has a lot of flavors we can make a
lot of different interesting things all
right i have some great ideas and as
always i'm excited to make it fancy
before we start check out our latest
merch at
shopmakingfancy.com here is what i got
cilantro mint butter lettuce ginger huge
limes tomato garlic jalapeno chicken
fries mayo yogurt red onion and eggs
from the pantry i got cumin seed salt
baking powder flour sugar kashmiri red
chili powder and vodka alright let's get
started
make it fancy
i have two chicken thighs seasoned with
salt half cup greek yogurt one teaspoon
of ginger i'm gonna just eyeball two
cloves of garlic our production manager
dj he's from india i
asked a lot about mahi from him seems
like there is a lot of things you can do
with maggi i'm doing one of them today
two tablespoons of lime juice one
teaspoon of kashmiri chili one
tablespoon of water and one package of
muggy seasoning mix well marinade
chicken thighs you want to completely
cover it i'm going to put this in the
refrigerator marinade at least four
hours or preferably overnight one cup
cilantro half cup meat one tablespoon
lime juice half jalapeno two cloves of
garlic half teaspoon of whole cumin
ginger half teaspoon of sugar salt
quarter cup of mayo it will give nice
texture add a little bit of water to
just blender get going blend this
together okay the sauce looks good i'll
keep this in the refrigerator until i
use it next boiling water i'm adding two
packs of maggi keep spice bucket for
later the packet instruction says cook
for two minutes but i want to make it
more soft and tender so i'm going to
cook about five to seven minutes seven
minutes later the noodle is very very
soft it's a opposite of al dente and i'm
going to drain let it sit for a while
until it is a little bit dry add this
overcooked noodles and two tablespoons
of flour i'm gonna blend this well and
the texture should look like mashed
potato sprinkle some flour on the
surface more flour and then you are
going to need almost like making gnocchi
start coming together one big dough it's
a little bit softer than a regular bread
dough cover this with plastic put this
in the refrigerator and rest this for 30
minutes i already have maggi noodles i
cooked according to the package
instructions and i didn't use the
seasoning i'm gonna crack two eggs whisk
them
i've met kanchan in new york she is
great she's a mom i aspire to be and
also she graduated harvard and her
cooking is kind of focused on like
healthy cooking and she has a lot of
knowledge so if you haven't follow her
you should follow her tossing eggs in
with noodles coat them evenly spray ring
mold put in a hot oil i'm dividing this
into four because i want to make four of
them so this is hot oil so be careful
when you do this we're using rubber
spatula
you want to compress as much as you can
cook
three to four minutes per side so noodle
is crispy so i'm going to take off the
mold and
flip this
i've fried the other side for three
minutes and it's nice and crispy on the
other side put on a paper towel so it
drains extra oil make two more and
moving on to the next step i have one
packet of maggi i'm going to use noodles
and you kind of want to make a cow
direction measure out 1 4 cup noodle
powder 3 4 cup of flour 1 teaspoon of
baking powder well combined and set this
aside add 2 package of maggi seasoning
mix well in a bowl one third cup of
yogurt two tablespoons of water one
tablespoon of vodka i'm adding vodka so
i can make the chicken coating crispy
and i learned this hack from tasty 101
fried chicken episode adding egg whites
mix well
i have the chicken thigh that i was
marinating cold
in the flour first and then dip in a
yogurt mix coat with muggy flour again
i'm going to fry chicken
at 350 about five to seven minutes one
side you are looking for golden brown
color and cook until inner temperature
reaches 165 drain oil in a pot chicken
looks nice
golden brown and crispy sprinkle some
flaky salt while it's still hot chicken
looks great but we have more things to
do i have chilled the dough sprinkle
some flour put some flour on top flour
to the rolling pin roll it into
square four inch by four quarter inch
stick using a pizza cutter cut in half
cut into stripes
i'm going to just cut top to make it a
little bit even sides i'm gonna just
separate it so easy to pick it up oil is
at 350 i'm going to fry this about two
to three minutes or until golden brown
i'm occasionally stirring so it doesn't
stick together and evenly brown this is
crazy it just looks like french fry
take this out from the oil this looks
great it's nice golden brown so i'm
going to finish them and move on to next
add in a bowl and i have one packet of
maggi seasoning cilantro for color
mixture fries are well coated with
seasoning
it's really good everything is kind of
fried so i want to make things a little
bit lighter so i made green sauce with
fresh art and i have fresh vegetables or
garnish ramen buns on bottom mushroom on
the bottom put lettuce
and put chicken so crispy and more green
sauce and tomato
onion but on top
such a big boy masala flies and we are
done
maggie fried chicken sandwich with maggi
fries very big and so festive
hi hi
here we go
oh my gosh you made like a maggie
burger yes you turned maggie into ramen
burger oh my gosh of course you did i
wish i could eat it through this zoom
situation
ooh the crunch
you should be so proud um i loved maggie
as a kid i haven't had maggie in a while
but that's the version i want to have
next so kanchan did i make maggie fancy
you made it so fancy i cannot even
handle it and i can't wait to eat it we
have one last thing to do three two one
make it
[Music]
you